the game is set between books 2 and
three so at the end of book two cor made
a really key decision in that she
allowed the connection between the
spirit world and the real world to be
permanently open and there's a lot of
consequences that came because of that
some of them good and some of them not
so good I thought opening the portal in
my lifetime would be an issue but it
turns out I also have to answer for
things I did aund lifetimes
ago we have four different elements that
you can use to bend each one of them has
their own strength but when you start
combining them within a single combo
becomes incredibly powerful so Platinum
games did a
combo and it made it last for something
like 45
seconds I mean it was just incredible so
I mean there's just so much potential
for this this fighting system not to
mention an avatar state which is going
to be
amazing I'm afraid y bending is blocked
Avatar
that's you're going to get Kora and team
Avatar so you're going to have m in in
there I hope you're not too rusty for
this bro me
and there off there's also some segments
where you get to hang out with Naga all
right girl let's get to the portal
they're a whole ton of fun uh really
highp speed traversal
stuff go get Legend of for it's going to
be an awesome
game